hey everyone I'm John Luke and I'm here
with Michael Heim Michael you got to see
a live demo and presentation for Forza
Motorsports so what's new let me start
with kind of the big uh picture that
they're trying to build with this new
Forza Motorsport
the thing that they emphasize was What's
called the builders cup and what's
interesting here is that traditionally
in racing games that have a career mode
you race and earn money to either buy
parts or buy new cars so what they're
trying to do with this game is well they
kept say calling it a car PG which kind
of does make sense to be honest because
instead of earning money you earn what's
called car points and you spend car
points like their XP to build out your
car so what you can always do is Respec
and what that does in practice is that
instead of racing for like an extra
thousand dollars whatever so I can
upgrade my suspension and then take it
out to the track and racing a bunch of
times so I can upgrade my exhaust or get
it a different intake or whatever
instead it feels like here's a pool of
XP that you can use to build your car
however you want and respecting you can
get those car points back by taking out
those parts so you're mixing and
matching different parts depending on
the races that you're doing with your
car so I think it's a really smart
system because I've played a lot of
racing Sims a lot of career modes over
time and I've I've kind of gotten tired
of that formula of like just earning
money or whatever so what this lets me
do is that okay I have a car and I maybe
I'm taking it into a cup or a race where
there's a lot more cornering and I need
to come out of the corner faster so uh
and if I just did a race where there's a
lot more straightaways I probably have a
lot I can invest a lot in engine
upgrades so I can hit the straightaways
faster in a particular race I go into
one that's a little bit more complex
with the sharper turns I can take those
parts back get my car points back and
then invest in maybe better suspension
better tires things like that so I think
the way they frame it is they want you
to build a better car rather than buy
better cars okay so uh I think that's
one of the more more important aspects
to their career mode they mentioned that
there's going to be a bunch of other
modes in Forza Motorsport they weren't
quite ready to talk about it so they're
really emphasizing and high highlighting
this Builder's cup mode the other thing
that you mentioned was they are going
big on AI and how uh they're gonna use
that to enhance the racing experience
yeah listen I'm not a mathematician I'm
not I'm not a computer scientist but I
did ask about AI because I think that's
very important for a racing game and
this when I mentioned the kind of the
monotony of sim racing in the past of
the formula of buying parts and stuff
like that another aspect to the manani
of previous racing Sims I felt was that
the AI became predictable where you know
some games have or a lot of racing games
have rubber bandings where like you know
if they're too far behind they're going
to catch up because the game pushes them
through so you can keep the race tight
and keep it interesting and the same
thing if you fall behind but of course
that's not realistic right that doesn't
happen in real life so they've kind of
retooled their machine learning AI for
the individual cars so to behave a lot
more like professional racing drivers
and one of the ways in which that
manifests is they're much more aware of
your position on the track and the way
they framed it is that instead of when
when the AI drivers are like if they're
messing up or falling behind instead of
them being sloppy they are timid so
they're a lot more hesitant to drive
aggressively so one way this can happen
is that if you're taking a turn and the
AI recognize that you're in their
driving line they're not going to just
like slam into you because you're in the
in their driving line professional
Racers don't do that so the AI is built
in a way to where it's adaptive and
understands what you're doing and your
position and then instead of them being
sloppy and maybe ramming into you as
you're trying to overtake what they what
they would do is they would slow down
they would be more timid and that would
be your opportunity to overtake them
because you know and I asked about F1
because I follow F1 very closely and I
asked them it's like well you know some
drivers are sloppy and sometimes they do
make mistakes and like those things will
happen they're not just gonna straight
up Ram into you because they're in your
way yeah so that makes the AI a lot
smarter and at least from what they've
told me is that the AI on the cars are
all
like there's no tricks that they do
like rubber banding in there that's all
everything that the AI does is what
another player it would be capable of
doing so they don't juice them because
they're like super far behind so it
makes for a much more realistic Driving
Experience and I think that's important
for racing Sims today so I want to see
of course I didn't get Hands-On so as
someone who's played a lot of racing
Sims I would love to get Hands-On to see
how that actually flows in a race
another thing you said they've been
changing is the way physics work yes
every racing Sim wants to upgrade their
physics model yeah cars to do we want
them to handle much more realistically
and those things are very complex
there's a whole bunch of mathematical
formulas and tables and data sets that
I'm not going to get involved in because
I don't actually know a lot of that
stuff but like I said I do play these
games and I could see the ways in which
those things change so like racing
simulations are constantly evolving and
they've said that they can upgrade or
update their physics model as time goes
on with this game and because they've
also said that their physics model is in
their Sim model is
more complex than some professional
racing teams so again I mentioned F1
because they the F1 teams build their
own racing Sims for their drivers to
test on right and we brought up like
McLaren is like no slander to the
McLaren F1 team but they said that like
they've been working on these games for
so long that an F1 team aren't
necessarily game developers who don't
have like 20 years of history of
building racing Sims so they mentioned
that their physics physics model is
getting better and more realistic and
you know being able to build a model in
the cars can react more realistically to
track conditions uh tire wear and things
like that those are the things you
expect out of a new racing Sim of course
but you know you don't I just wanted to
make sure and check with them it's like
oh yeah I played a lot of fours in
Motorsport 7. you know is are you
working on this aspect of course the
answer is yes I'm excited for Forza
Motorsport I know a lot of horizon games
came out and I love the Horizon games
and I play a lot of Gran Turismo 7 when
it came out and I still have I still
have room in my heart for a good racing
Sim so I am genuinely excited uh for
this game and you know some people might
look at it and think oh well it's
another track racing Sim but uh I'm a
sicko for those kinds of things and yeah
for for Xbox you know Forza has been one
of their Staples so if if they're gonna
put a lot of eggs into that basket I
would like to see uh their the fruits of
Labor come to fruition and yeah I'm I'm
excited to play around with that
Builders cup and see how things have
changed well thank you very much for
your Insight Michael and uh I think you
and all the other racing sickos will
have a chance to check out the game for
themselves on October 10th and for all
things Forza
stay here at Camp spot